we are re-examining our relationship
with China the sorts of the virus and
whether it was deliberate or
deliberately misleading right now the
read on all of that with retired
Brigadier General Anthony
tada um general good to have you you've
heard the stories in the back and forth
they recently that is the Chinese up the
number of deaths that are being reported
out of Wuhan a little over 3,000 but
they're their total death count right
now is remarkably low when you consider
a little bit more than 8800 compared to
where we are that it isn't and doesn't
seem realistic so even now are are you
trusting the numbers you're getting out
of China I would not trust anything that
comes out of China right now you know
what happened it's really whether it was
a deliberate manufactured virus or
something that happened an accident and
the Wuhan testing center there the
Chinese government deliberately withheld
information deliberately manipulated
information and the numbers that you
just articulated or an example of that
they suppressed whistleblowers who were
trying to talk about how bad this was
and particularly they human a human
contagion aspect of this China said it
wasn't eh and then the whu-oh was a
puppet for China and said the same thing
and so it is was a deliberate act of
misinformation by the Chinese government
and it is tantamount to detonating a
nuclear bomb accidentally in killing a
hundred and fifty thousand people it's
the same thing in my view and so we
really need to take a step back and and
I think the president and his team and
in general Milley and his team and the
secretary of defense are all focused on
getting the accurate information so that
we can assess and appropriately respond
of course the priority right now is to
save American lives and that's what the
president's doing if the Chinese did do
people they do the president states as
well who said as you know general back
in January that they were
working hard on this that that were
being very transparent so was he fooled
by them as well no III don't think so I
think what happened is you know
intelligence you read intelligence every
single day you make the best assessments
that you get from the folks that you
have in country and in the region and
you make assessments and the assessments
that were coming out where that this was
not human to human
and then the president made a very good
decision very early on it was very
unpopular to shut down travel from China
I think base as much of an intelligence
as one instinct to shut down that travel
and that directly had saved tens of
thousands of lives from my point of view
and then to shut down travel from Europe
and so as as we got more clarity on the
information on what I would call the
enemy situation from my military days
you gain a better picture it's like a
movement to contact as we used to call
it and you get more information every
day as you go as you as you get further
into the situation your information
clarifies and then you have better and
better responses and you're able to
overcome it and then take over the
situation as the president has done with
his task force and and standing up that
task force and doing the daily press
briefings and getting the accurate
information out there despite we're
quite frankly what the much in the
mainstream media has sided with China on
this thing inexplicably well it's
because the the virus and the damage to
the economy and to the health of
Americans you know it works against the
president so the the media wants that to
happen more to further that narrative
but the president has been very strong
on this year my general there is still
some culpability there is still right I
mean it doesn't mean it's easy to play
Monday Morning Quarterback now but a
Peter Navarro was warning him about
stuff and what there were enough
mistakes made that it's not exclusively
on China not exclusively on the World
Health Organization right I would say
this is exclusively within the realm of
China and try
lives and China misinformation there
there's we should give no quarter kneel
to China there there should be nothing
spared this is a communist dictatorship
that hid the information they shut down
travel within their own country but they
allowed the virus to go to other
countries they intentionally allowed
this to happen and knowing how bad it
was and they shut down two centers they
shut down whistleblowers they shut down
travel to protect themselves but they
let others that were inspected you go
around the world and they've killed 150
thousand people all right so much we
don't know but you do raise a good
question here that if we can't trust
them on this medical issue can we trust
them on what they have promised us on on
trade that's one of the issues we'll be
getting into as well the me general
thank you very very much well the more
Thank You Neal